[Music]
on hadrian's wall in northumberland a
flaming arrow was fired as part of a
chain of beacon lighting celebrating 70
years of the queen's reign
fires were lit across the uk continuing
a tradition linking beacons to royal
anniversaries begun by queen victoria
for her diamond jubilee in 1897
beacon lighting events were staged
across the uk
on the pier head in cardiff bay the
abandoned drums of the royal welsh
regiment performed
in scotland
the menstrual scout group climbed the
highest peak between sterling and
edinburgh to light a beacon erected for
the queen's silver jubilee 45 years ago
in county tyrone in northern ireland
girl guides took part in activities the
queen herself would have known from her
time in the movement
i've just made a teddy bear and i've
been on the inflatables and we're going
to be doing arts and crafts later so
it's going to be fun
perhaps the most unusual beacon lighting
was by bride and groom emma and matt
jackson until they arrived for their
pandemic delayed wedding in tangmia in
west sussex they had no idea they'd been
lined up for the task and just thought
it'd be really special to have it on
this day and you know celebrate you know
all their jubilee televisions that are
going on
[Music]
for the first time this was an
international event billed as lighting
up the uk and commonwealth one of the
first beacons to be lit was in
wellington in new zealand
in australia a beacon was lit on
canberra's lake burley
griffin oh yay
[Music]
yay
closer to home the beacons were
announced by town criers in market
places and high streets across the uk
the official countrywide start to the
long bank holiday weekend
everything that's going on in the world
so it's nice to have something like this
yeah it cheers you up yeah it does yeah
this is a jubilee like no other it's
history being celebrated as history is
being made for the longest reigning
monarch we have ever known